- Today, I'm going to
talk about the 10 things
that I did right and wrong
with my book launch.
(soft booming)
(upbeat rock music)
What's up Believe Nation?
I'm excited to be here.
The book has been out for a little bit.
We've gotten some great
reviews, great testimonials,
it's been amazing seeing the
results people been getting
by going through the
book, and the audiobook,
and the ebook.
It's been an awesome experience,
and I've been thinking.
I've been thinking over
the past couple months
what I did right that really helped,
that really worked, and what I did wrong.
So, that one, if I ever
write a book again,
I've learned a little bit,
and two, for those of you
who are thinking about
writing a book,
these may be some
lessons that you can take
to avoid having some of the pitfalls
that I went through in
launching my first book.
So, let's start off with what I did right.
The first thing was, I
fought for what I wanted.
When I first talked to
me agent about this book,
he didn't think it was going to be a book.
He thought it was a work book,
like a little tiny worksheet thing,
and my literary agent felt the same way,
that it wasn't really a full-on book,
and I had to fight for it.
I had to prove to them
that it was a full book,
that this is the book,
right?
Like, I wrote twice this amount.
Right, this is 65,000
words, something like that,
and that's a typical book.
I wrote 120,000 words.
I wrote two books worth of content,
'cause it was so much in there
that you could potentially
apply your one word to,
and at the beginning, they didn't see it,
and so I had to show them,
and I fought for it,
and I think a lot of times,
at the start,
you hear music, there's that
quote about you hearing music
and so you dance, and the
people who can't hear the music
think you're crazy.
You see this person dancing,
you can't hear the music,
you think they're crazy.
It's kind of like, what entrepreneurs are,
is what I was doing at the
start of this book process.
I had this vision for what I wanted to do,
and people around me thought it was crazy,
and so talking about
it more wouldn't help,
I had to show them.
And I was really proud that
I fought for what I wanted,
'cause I'm really proud of
the book that came out of it.
So, if you're really convinced
that your idea is a good one,
and it has to be created, fight for it.
The second thing is I used a
structure that I wanted, too.
I was really adamant that...
I hate reading books that have
long, long, long chapters.
It really bothers me, right?
Most books have these crazy long chapters,
and I would find myself
reading the same page
over, and over, and over again,
and I would find myself
forgetting where I left off,
and I hate closing a book
in the middle of a chapter,
'cause then, I forget what happened.
I want to end it at
the end of the chapter.
End it on bulleted paragraph, something.
Some clear demarcation so I know where
to pick up the next time,
and so what I wanted to do was be able
to have a book where every
page was easy to read,
like the language itself was easy to read,
but you could pick it up at any point
and exit at any point.
And so, if you look, for
those of you have the book,
you know what I'm talking about.
See like, there's the
end, I could stop there.
I could flip to the next page.
Right, there's another chapter
title at the start, right?
Whatever page you're on,
there's a clear point to
stop reading if you want.
It flows,
but there's a clear point to stop reading.
I have quotes at the top
of almost every page,
and I like that format,
and at the start, again,
my publisher wasn't a fan of it,
and my way around that was just to
not tell them,
(laughing)
and just keep going with it.
They wanted longer
paragraphs, longer pages,
and not have so many quotes at the top,
and I just kept going,
basically to the point
where we got to deadline
and it was going to be
too late to change it,
and again, I'm so glad that I did that
because it's been one of the things
that people like most about the book,
aside from the content,
which is amazing, right?
People like that it's easy to read,
and that you can pick it up at any point,
and there's a lot of motivational quotes
and things that tie in.
A lot of practical examples,
and so I'm really happy that
I stayed with the structure
that I had in my mind, as well.
And this is generally a good lesson.
If you're frustrated with something,
you know, I was frustrated
with the typical reading experience.
Let me find an example.
Here's an example.
Here's something.
Somebody gave me this book.
Legendary book, said
it changed their life.
A lot of people talked about
this book, Atlas Shrugged.
Legendary book, and I load it,
and it's like, look at,
look at this.
Look at that.
It's just
1,000 pages of
intense
stuff,
and so I need to prepare
myself to read this book,
and it's only because it
became so highly recommended
that it's even still sitting on my shelf.
Otherwise, it's crazy.
And so, if you're frustrated
with an experience,
you're frustrated with
reading books like that,
you're frustrated with anything
that's happening in your life,
it creates an opportunity.
That's what entrepreneurs do, right?
We solve problems.
We see a problem,
and instead of complaining about it,
we find a solution,
which is what I tried to do in the book.
I was frustrated with the
regular book experience,
and so I created one that
I thought was a better one,
and thankfully, a lot of you guys agree.
The number three thing I did right
was I got a test audience.
This was another surprising,
really interesting thing
that is not done in the
publishing industry.
So, I finished my manuscript,
had 120,000 words,
and I said well, how do
we split test the titles,
and how do we split test the cover,
and how do we split test the content
to see, right, like in the movie business,
they'll make a movie,
and then they'll put it
in front of a test audience,
and they'll see what their reaction was.
Did people cry when
you wanted them to cry?
Were they yawning and falling
asleep in the movie or not,
and what points did they enjoy, not enjoy?
When you're looking at
creating a new product,
you go to a test audience.
Here's a new chocolate bar I want to make.
Okay, let's go sample it
and see what people think.
Oh, there's too much peanuts,
oh, there's too much corn
syrup, whatever, right?
You test it, you test, you test a product.
Great products come when
you mix what you love doing
with what the market wants, right?
The
business basics.
Yes, you have to love it.
Yes, you have to see an opportunity.
Yes, you have to create
something from your soul,
and at the same time, the
audience has to like it.
There has to be a need for it.
Otherwise, you're just in a hobby.
You're doing something that you love,
but nobody cares about it,
so you're just often a hobby.
I didn't want this to be a hobby.
I wanted this to have an impact,
and in the publishing
world, there is no sampling.
There is no test audience.
It's just not done,
which was surprising, and so I said,
okay, I'm going to make
my own test audience.
If this isn't part of the system,
this isn't part of the process,
I'm going to make it part of the process,
'cause that's how you
launch a successful product,
and so I got 30 people,
half of whom were entrepreneurs
and half of whom were not entrepreneurs.
I felt like it would do
well with the entrepreneurs.
I wasn't so sure about
the non-entrepreneurs,
but it's good to get their
feedback, regardless.
And I gave them the
120,000 word manuscript,
and they went through it.
I got it back after them,
and they highlighted.
I kept track of who highlighted what.
Not so much concerned about
this person's individual
opinion, but as a whole.
These 30 people who reviewed it.
What were the most highlighted passages?
What were the comments
that people liked the most?
What were some parts that people found
were really confusing?
And, I took that to take
my 120,000 word manuscript
down to the 65,000 words
that we have today.
I cut out the chapters
that people didn't resonate with as much.
I added chapter highlights
from the quotes that people
underlined the most, right?
Knowing how people react to your stuff
can help you make a better product.
And so, I'm super glad that
I went through that exercise,
and also really grateful to the 30 people
who reviewed it for me,
'cause it gave me a lot of
insanely valuable information
that I could take the book
from 120,000 words down to 65,
and my agent wants to take that other
55,000 words
that we cut out and turn that into a book?
No, that's not, that's
not, that's not a book.
I'll throw away that book.
If I'm going to do another book,
it'll be somethin' totally different,
and I think that's part of
being an entrepreneur, too,
and being good at what you do,
is you create
and throw away
more than what most people
even try to make.
So many people just sit there with an idea
and do nothing with it.
Where the success entrepreneurs, they try.
They try, they try, they try,
they create, they create, they create,
they are prolific with their creations,
and not everything is going
to hit, and that's okay,
and you take the best and you
keep moving forward with it,
and the stuff that
didn't work, it's great,
and I think it's good
to get into the practice
of creating and throwing
away more than most people
will even just create.
Throw away more than most
people even try to create.
You will fail your way to success,
and so I'm really glad
I had my test audience
because they gave me the
critical information,
and then also, when I was going
through the back and forth
with the editor, and the
publisher to say, "Hey, keep this,
"don't keep this.".
I had data.
It's not just my opinion,
'cause they had opinions, they'd say,
"Oh, we don't like this.",
or "We like this.".
Well listen, we tested it,
here's what people think.
Real life people who are
entrepreneurs and not entrepreneurs
who are going to read the book.
Here's what they think,
and we will use that test data
to be able to fight for the parts
that I really wanted to
incorporate into the book.
So, really helpful.
The number four thing I did right
was I did it myself.
Getting into this industry,
I realized how many books
are not actually written
by the author.
There's ghost person with no credit,
their audiobooks are
read by somebody else.
It's just basically putting their name
on the front of a book,
and I definitely had a team who helped me,
but most of the parts
that are in the book,
and all of the parts
that are opinion pieces,
it was me, I wrote it.
I wrote it, it may have been edited,
it may have been corrected,
some grammatical issues,
but I wrote it, and it was one of the,
actually the best things from the editors
was they were, they
went through everything
with a fine-tooth comb,
and there's actually still a few errors
and typos we found in the book,
but they went through everything
and corrected a lot of the grammar,
which is great.
I'm super grateful for
that, but I wrote it.
It's my words, it's my
content, it's my meat,
and I think as a result,
the product is better.
I remember I was picking up an audiobook
for a book I was really excited to read,
I forget what it was,
and then I found out that the person
wasn't actually the person.
It was read by some actor.
It's great, it's nothing
against the actor,
it's just not the person.
It's not the guy.
I want to hear from the guy,
and so when we talked
about doing the audiobook,
I insisted on doing it.
Now, they wanted me, which was good.
Most authors don't want to
put in the work to do it,
and of course I'm going to do it.
I need to do it.
It's my book!
It's my voice, I need to get it out there!
So really, I think doing it myself
was a super important part
of the book's success.
And the number five thing I did right
was I also got a team.
As much as point number
four was I did it myself,
I got a team for all the things
that I wasn't good at,
or I wasn't having a lot of success at,
or I just needed help with, right?
So, I had my two agents
who made sure that a deal happened,
and helped me find the right publisher
with Penguin Random House,
where we found the publisher who cared,
who liked the message, who was on board,
who supported the vision,
and that was important,
'cause I don't know if
I would have gotten that
on my own, and I didn't want
to publish without a publisher.
I had people who helped
with some of the research
on the book.
I think about all of the
quotes that are in the book,
and how many of them
Jason helped find for me,
and just helped being an amazing filter
so I didn't have to go out
and do all of the research.
One of my friends, another
entrepreneur, Jennifer,
helped me with a lot of the
interviews that I was doing.
The third part of this book
is me interviewing people
who were also living their one word,
and also plotted to their business,
and went from $50,000
dollars full-time income
up to $150 million dollars in revenue
off of their one word,
and so sitting down and interviewing them.
What I find is when
I'm doing an interview,
I'm either in the present
and with that person,
or I'm taking notes, and
have a hard time doing both,
and so, Jen sat in with
me on hours and hours
and hours of interview.
Each one was three to
four hours, at least.
She was takin' the notes,
and she asked a couple
of great questions, too,
and then she compiled the
notes and put it together,
and it was really helpful,
and so if the words
aren't my words, right?
If the words were Christopher Gavigan
from the Honest Company,
then she would write those words,
and the words that were me, I wrote,
which is most of the book.
But, super helpful that we had that team.
The guys who are on the audio side
were paying so much attention to
the quality and the detail,
and the audiobook came out fantastic
in a way that I wouldn't
be able to do myself,
and so I think it's really
important to understand
where it is that you shine.
I want to come up with a strategy,
I want to come up with the ideas,
I want to write the content
that's coming from my voice, my opinions.
I want to be the voice when
we're doing the audio recording.
I want to be the guy on the
video, there's video bonuses
for people that bought the ebook.
I want to be that because
that's the most important
use of my time.
The other stuff, I'm not great at,
and we can get it done a lot faster
if I had people around me,
and so I think that's important
to any successful launch
of any product.
Understand what you're really good at
and going all in on that,
and surrounding yourself with people
who can support you in the other projects.
So, those were the five
things I did right,
now let's get to the five
things that I did wrong.
Up first is the bulk orders
versus the one, two, five.
I really
focused on
bulk orders,
'cause I was told to focus
on bulk orders, right?
I think you buy the one, but
then you can also buy 10,
and then 25, forget what
the different packages were
of books.
And one of the bits of
advice that came back from
one of the guys on my team was,
"You should do a package for
two and a package for five.
"If you buy two books, you get this,
"you buy five books, you get this.",
and the advice came while
we're already into the process,
and the website was pretty
much built with all the offers,
and I didn't take it, and I should've.
Where I think a lot of people jumping
from one book to 10 books is a big jump,
but some people would buy two books,
and if you give them
an incentive to do it,
or buy five books and give
them an incentive to do it,
they would.
So, most of the sales
that you end up making
are going to be at the lower end,
as opposed to people
buying 100 books at a time,
and so giving some kind
of reward and incentive
for somebody to buy one extra
book, or four extra books,
could really make a difference.
Number two is the lead time on the cover
and on the creative.
So, this is something
that I did not anticipate.
One of the things I was really adamant on,
was I wanted each page
to be the end, so as I,
let me load up any page.
Random page.
Oh, actually this one works.
Okay, so you see how
here, it's at the top,
there's a header, there's a
quote, and then there's content?
And if I flip to the next page,
it's not, right?
It's in the middle, oh where am I, here.
It's in the middle, and
there's a quote and content,
and down on this side, it's
in the middle, quote, content.
I wanted it to be at the top.
I wanted each page to be at the top.
I wanted the headline to be at the top,
and then a quote, and then
each thing underneath,
and
we couldn't make it work.
It was either I'm so
adamant about that structure
that I walk away from the deal,
because with the timeline set up,
we couldn't make it work,
'cause I wasn't using
the right template, and I'm
looking at 65,000 words,
having to rewrite and
re-shift everything around.
It wouldn't work for the timeline,
and so that was super frustrating.
Also, the cover, I'm
actually not a huge fan of.
The cover was, the cover came
really late in the process.
I, again, not knowing this process,
assumed that we'd have
time to go back and forth
and work with different
designers, and split test ideas,
and it's not, it was
basically here's the idea
from our art department,
what do you think?
And the only room was for
a couple minor tweaks and improvements,
and then that's basically
what you go with.
Well, we need an idea,
we need a final version in two weeks.
It's like...
If you don't have a designer,
if you don't have that skill in-house
to go out and find somebody
and get everything done,
and get it approved.
We just ran out of time.
That was on me, assuming that
we would have enough time.
I assumed that the cover matters,
the cover is important,
the cover we would spend
a good amount of time on.
Now, my publisher loves the cover.
My agent loves the cover.
I'm not a big fan of the cover.
But, again, it's one of those things.
Do I want to hold up
the launch of this book
because of the cover?
Am I going to walk away from the deal
No, because the content
inside is really, really good,
and if I did it again in
terms of another book,
I'd make sure I have a lot of lead time.
I'd start designing the
cover from the beginning
to make sure that that art is just as good
as the content and the art
that's inside the book.
I think it's important.
The number four thing I did wrong
was understanding the
importance of the credo.
The credo has become
such an important part
of the process, as I walk
people through it offline.
So, the credo is the three things
that make up your one word.
So, you got your one word,
and then the three things that add clarity
make up the credo, and so I have believe,
and in the believe, there's passion,
you know, believe in what you're doing.
There's confidence, which
is believe in yourself,
and there's conviction,
which is believe that
it's going to work out.
So, believe, the one word, breaks down
into passion, self-confidence,
and conviction,
and that is a extremely valuable exercise
for people to go through,
and it's in the book,
but it's in the campaign
section of the book,
where I realize in talking to people
and going through the process afterwards,
that really, it should part of core,
because that understanding
is not just about marketing,
which is campaign, it's about you.
It helps you with your life,
and you make important decisions,
and you live a better version
of what you want to do,
and so it's buried more
into the campaign section
instead of being more
upfront in the credo.
So, if I had rewrite the content,
that's one thing that I'd really focus on.
Moving the credo earlier and
making it more important.
It's something that I walk people through
when I'm coaching them individually,
the people on my team,
but it's not nearly
important enough in the book.
So, for those of you who have it,
pay extra special attention
to the limited pages
on the credo, because
it's really important.
And number five is
underestimating the importance
on leadership.
I don't really talk about
leadership in this book.
I never really thought of
it as a leadership book.
It was more as a
self-leadership book, I guess
you to manage yourself, and
the people that build the team
and hire the right people, but not how to
lead people with their one word,
and understand them to be better,
and I've been getting a lot of interviews,
a lot of requests, a lot
of speaking opportunities
around leadership,
and it's been so interesting
how people are using the book.
So, we have CEOs and
entrepreneurs reading the book,
and I think about their
team, and they realize,
huh, my team should go through this.
Everybody should find their
one word and find their credo,
and if I understand
what their one word is,
and I understand what their credo is,
then I know how to push them
to get the best thing that they want.
So, as an example,
any organization will have goals, right?
We want to hit this amount in revenue.
We all have these common goals
that we're shooting towards,
but how we go and execute that,
and how we motivate and push
people will be different,
so if our goal is to hit a
million dollars in revenue,
and I've got somebody under me
who they're responsible for
driving that project forward.
What's their one word?
If their one word is grit,
then I have to push them
around gettin' the work done
and not making excuses,
and let's go, go, go, go.
If their one word is creativity,
then I have to push them around coming up
with creative ideas.
I know that if I'm just telling them
exactly what to do, somebody
whose one word is creativity
is going to suffocate, 'cause
they need to be creative, right?
We still have our goal of
what we want to accomplish,
but the path to get there will change
based on the people that
you have underneath you,
and often what you'll find is
when you break down the credo,
there's one part of that at least,
that people are falling short of,
so if self-confidence is
part of somebody's credo,
and you see them not being self-confident,
you're given the tools to help push them.
I believe a leader's role
is to take somebody
who you see has a lot of potential.
They could be up here,
they're down here right now.
Your job is to help them close the gap.
That's your job as a leader,
is to see potential
and help close the gap.
And so, by understanding somebody's
one word and their credo,
they're giving you the tools to help them.
'Cause if you think everybody
thinks like you, they don't.
If you think everybody has the
same values and credo as you,
they don't.
And so, understanding that,
and not just seeing everybody
as you, and everybody as, well,
here's how I would solve it.
That's not going to help everybody.
There's going to be a ton of people
who won't be able to solve the problem
the exact same way you do,
and that's where leaders often mess up.
That's why a lot of,
you look at in baseball,
some of the best baseball
hitters make terrible coaches,
'cause they just try to
teach people how they do it,
where what you need to
do is understand them
to teach them in a way
that makes sense to them,
and knowing what their
credo and their one word is.
It's giving you the tools
to say this is what I
feel is important to me,
and so when you see them
falling short on those things,
you know how to push them,
and it's not pushing them for you.
Yes, if they do well,
it helps the company,
but it's pushing them for them.
They've told you that
this is important to them.
They've told you creativity,
or believe, or confidence
is important to them,
and so when they're not living
up to their own expectations,
you know how to push them.
So, it's been such an
important leadership tool,
and a lot of that stuff isn't in the book.
It almost makes sense as a sequel,
although it's not the next
book that I want to write.
So, anyway, I wish that
was somewhere in the book,
and if I was rewriting it
again, I would include that.
So, those are the five things I did right,
and the five things that I did wrong
that I would keep in
mind for the next time
I'm writing a book, and hopefully you guys
learned from it as well.
Let me jump to some of the
questions that came in recently
from you guys.
Okay, first up is replicant70.
"Bless you, Evan.
"Your excitement is so infectious.
"I pre-ordered the copy already,
"so a study group format
would really enhance
"my experience of your work.
"Also, as someone who is
also super keen to write
"a book of his own, capturing
your book publishing journey
"is mega valuable to me.
"Could all the relevant
videos be bundled up
"into a book writing toolbox?
"You so deserve your success
"for all the value you are giving
"to so many people all over the world.
"Don't ever leave us, my friend.".
Lots of love in here,
I really appreciate it.
So, we're just finishing,
we just finished seven
weeks of the book club.
I made the book club, which
was a virtual hangout.
We hung out once a week for an hour
and talked about different chapters.
There's seven chapters, so
each was its own hangout,
and I did that that because
I want people to get it.
I want people to read the book,
not just buy 10 copies and
have them sit on your shelf.
Read it, do the exercises,
I want you to get value.
It's important to me that
you read it and apply it
to your life and your business,
and get results from it,
and not just buy another book
that does nothing for you.
So, that was a really exciting process
that we just finished last week.
All of the videos that
are around Your One Word,
there is a playlist.
If you go to the main
channel and scroll down,
there's one of the playlists,
I think it's called Your One Word.
All the videos that I've done,
that I've documented from the beginning,
from the idea to the writing,
to the excitement of launching,
to the pains of negotiate,
and all the problems I went through.
Every week, there's a new video
that I've been putting up
for, I don't know, two years.
So, there's lots to learn.
I would encourage you,
if you're trying to write your own book,
to go through that experience,
and hopefully, you'll be able to learn
what it takes to write a
book with a major publisher.
That was the intention
to be able to document
the series, and also have
it as an educational tool
for everybody else who's writing a book.
And in terms of leaving you,
you know, I do the
things that I love doing,
and right now, I still love YouTube,
I still love makin' videos.
It's my favorite platform
to connect with people,
and as long as I love doin' it,
as long as you guys are enjoying it,
I will still be here.
Next up, Luke William.
"Evan, how can I get a
signed copy of your book?
"I just finished listening on Audibles
"and I'd love to have a signed copy.
"Hastag #believe."
Best way to get a signed copy
is to come to Toronto,
and let's meet
and bring a copy.
There's been people who
I've had coffee with
and talked about their business.
There's been some people
who just stopped by,
you know I was at Toronto Dance Salsa
doing something else,
and just a quick five
minutes in the hallway.
If you're ever in the city,
you want to visit one of
the most beautiful cities
in the world and potentially meet,
but I can't guarantee
that we're going to be able to have time
to grab a coffee, but at
least for five minutes,
just to maybe take a selfie
and sign the book, I'd be happy to.
That's the best way.
Otherwise, if I'm on the road,
I'm coming to LA, and Orlando, and Paris.
You know, if I'm ever in
the city that you're in,
the best way there is if
you're on my newsletter list,
I'll email the people in
that city that I'm going to,
and we usually find a way to meet up
if I have some extra time.
Next up is Nora.
"Thank you, Evan, for the shout out,
"I really appreciate it.
"I'm reading your book,
"still trying to figure out my one word.
"I am between two, explore, and create,
"and it's hard to find a common
word connecting them both.
"Any advice would be
greatly appreciated.".
This actually is common
when people have multiple words
and they're trying to figure out
how do I get it down to one?
I get that there's a,
you want to get it, you want
the sense of accomplishment,
you want to rush to it and say,
here it is, here's my goal,
I got it!
You know, I accomplished it.
As entrepreneurs, we are go-getters.
I really encourage you to take
your time to figure it out.
This is one of the most
important exercises
you're ever going to do in your life.
In my opinion, understanding yourself,
having that self-awareness,
and then building an entire
life and business around it.
It's important to spend
the time to make sure
you get it done properly.
I know that may be hard to hear for us
out and about go-getters,
but it's also important
to make sure that you have the right one.
So, when going through this exercise,
I encourage people to look at two things.
The first is, see if one
fits under the other.
So, you have create and explore.
I talked about having the one word
and then the credo underneath.
The credo is the three things
that help define your one word.
Believe equals passion,
equals self-confidence,
equals conviction.
That's what it means to me.
Does one fit under the other?
So, you have explore and create.
Could explore be your one word,
and create is under it,
and you have two others
that are under explore.
Or, could create be your one word
and explore is under it,
and you have two more next to explore.
Are they equal level of importance,
or can one fit under the other?
It's a really important question
because once you start
adding some definition to it,
you can often realize that
this one helps me define
the other one, and the other one
is actually the most important.
If they are equal importance to you,
then I'd be looking at, okay,
what is one thing above it?
Right, I use the example
in my book of my father,
who was going through.
He had heart, was his one
word, but he didn't know it.
He ended up with, he started with
he loves, he cares about people.
Massively cares, he's
just a genuine human being
and doesn't like to see suffering,
and he loves adventure.
Motorcycles, and zip-lining,
and fun adventures.
So, how do those, those
seem totally opposite.
I mean, at least create and
explore are kind of close.
His seemed totally opposite.
Caring and adventure
seemed totally opposite,
and what came down to was heart.
Heart is both.
Heart is caring for people,
and heart is going off and
doing something adventurous,
your heart gets pumping,
and so that worked out for him.
So, that's a little creative
way to figure it out.
Is there something that can
connect create and explore?
At the surface, it feels
like the first one,
where one fits under the other,
but at the end of the day,
this is your one word.
This is who you are.
It has to be something that you love,
and the more you sleep on it,
and the more you think about it,
it'll either become more and more right
or more and more wrong.
If you doubt it more, and
more, and more, and more,
then it's wrong.
If you like it more, and
more, and more, and more,
then it's right.
And so with time, it'll add more clarity.
Last up is Anita.
"I missed it again!
"We need some calendar
and notification system.
"Please think of something.
"J-Ryze and Mihovilj have put
their heads into this too.
"Go team.".
I think this was in relation
to one of the live book streams
that I did.
I don't know if I'm doing
any more of the book
live hangouts, we'll see where it goes.
The book series
is something to play with now, right.
It was easy to talk
about what I was doing,
and then the book was finished,
and so it became, okay, how
am I going to market the book,
and then that came out, and
then the book was launched,
and I did the live hangouts,
and so now we're into
this interesting phase
where I'm thinking what do
I do with this books series?
I'd love your feedback if you guys want to
put something in the comments below,
and see how this series continues,
or maybe it doesn't,
and we do some other new series.
In terms of notifications
for any live session,
the easiest way is one,
if you subscribe, obviously it's easy.
You get notified by email.
And two, if you click that bell.
You see a lot of YouTubers now saying
click the bell.
You'll get notifications.
We
are
thinking about some other method.
Either from our website or
newsletter or something.
The major ones I'll do on my newsletter,
if it's a big hangout on the main channel.
I also have another channel
just for live hangouts,
and so if you want more live stuff
and you want to ask me
questions one-on-one,
that's a great place to subscribe to.
We'll link it up and you can
head over there and subscribe.
And then, also, Friday mornings,
I play League of Legends on Twitch,
and I answer questions.
And so, if you have a question,
you want to hit me up live,
every Friday morning at 9:00 a.m. Eastern,
you could jump on with other
members of Believe Nation.
You can chat, you can watch
me play League of Legends
and cheer me on as well as
answer your business questions
to help you with your one word
or whatever else your
facing in your business.
So, that's it for now, guys.
It's a long video, but I
wanted to get my thoughts
and help answer some questions.
I learned a lot in this entire process,
and I'm better armed with more information
for the next time through.
Again, I would love your feedback
and thoughts and questions
around the book, if you have
any questions you want to share,
put it down in the comments,
and I'll answer you next week,
and also your thoughts on
what you want this series
to look like and how
you want it to continue,
super (mumbles) your feedback.
Leave it down below.
Thank you guys so much.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(soft booming)